hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
Supernatural so much happen so Metatron
came back all-out civil war broke out
between the Angel factions and we
learned out who Ezekiel really is so
since there's a lot of stuff to get
through I'm gonna do my top 10 moments
then I'll do my review and then I'll
talk about some of the big things that
are coming up as well as the bonus
videos I'm gonna be doing be sure to
subscribe to get everything and so it
begins
it's angel Civil War so on one side you
have the control freak Bartholomew and
on the other side you have this
anarchist Malachi watch where you step
things just got stabby number 9 the
choir of angels so this is just funny
because the group Malachi's faction
chose to inhabit is a church choir and a
group of angels is called a choir of
angels number 8 FBI agent Castiel
so somebody high-fived Dean for leaving
that badge with him how awesome was it
to see him so pumped up to play a secret
agent number 7 Castiel's first beer as a
human so this was awesome just because
he did it so casually it's almost like
he's totally acclimating to life as a
human right now remember how awkward it
was when he had sex for the first time
with April number 6 Castillo's prayer
montage so this almost looked like he
was practicing yoga but it was funny
just to watch him get so frustrated with
prayer the way a normal human would Anna
was fun to see Muriel answer the door
looking just like sheriff Jody
no five gadreel revealed a lot of you
guys thought that Ezekiel was gonna turn
out to be a bad person and you were half
right he is a bad person but he's
technically a good angel who's just
doing bad things because he thinks he
has no other choice which is kind of
where Castiel's character is at the
moment number four Castiel learns the
truth about gadreel so this was a lot
like that scene in The Sixth Sense where
Bruce Willis finds out he's been a ghost
the whole time Ezekiel's been dead this
whole time cue the scary music
number three Metatron appears and he has
a plan so just watching him casually
stroll into frame was really surprising
but his heaven 2.0 story was just a
little funny mostly because it made me
think of Revenge of the Nerds
we're gonna remake heaven except without
all the sucky angels maybe some of the
funny ones though number two
Castiel gets his grace back this was
such a satisfying moment for the
character and really is going to help
drive the plot forward in the future
because now Castiel could fight but
getting his grace back was just the
first step and the really interesting
thing about all of this is that he kind
of
thinks of himself as like a monster now
like he had to get his hands bloody to
do this so that being said once this is
all over do you think that he will still
feel like he is worthy of heaven
remember the last episode of Walking
Dead too far gone and my number one
moment the death of Kevin so this is
traumatic for a number of reasons one
kevin was an awesome person and he was a
tragic character to begin with remember
he had to watch his mother get killed
but to Sam is the one that killed him
remember he did not know that gadreel
was inside of Sam Dean never told him so
he thinks that Sam killed him but let me
know your favorite moments were in the
comments below
it didn't make my list but my honorable
mentioned would be Castiel talking about
April she was so hot till she started
torturing me overall the episode is now
tied for my favorite all-time episode at
least from season 9 of Supernatural the
Felicia Day Charlie episode the one off
is my other favorite mostly just because
it's so fun but the reason why I liked
this episode so much is because it was
so intense they weren't afraid to kill
off a major character like Kevin editor
of the Metatron heaven 2.0 and Angel
Civil War storylines forward in such a
meaningful way one of the things that I
feel like Supernatural could really
benefit from at this point is learning
from shows like arrow and the way they
serialized stories in such a big way
what that means is that every single
episode is dedicated towards moving the
major plots forward let me know what you
think would you rather see Supernatural
do serialized stories like arrow or do
you really like the one-off episodes
either way supernatural is back on
January 14th but I will be doing bonus
episodes in between now and then be sure
to subscribe to get them let me know
what you want to see in them the next
episode when we come back is gonna be
awesome because obviously it was so
traumatic to watch Kevin die but now we
get to capture gadreel and try to expel
him from Sam that's going to take a lot
of help from Crowley but it's basically
going to be gadreel tied up in a chair
so we will get our revenge at least as
an audience so hopefully that will be
satisfying
tomorrow is important because on arrow
we're going to see the flash for the
first time I'll also try and post a
bonus video just for the flash as well
but American Horror Story is back to and
remember I usually post those videos on
Thursday morning right now click here to
learn all about the flash on arrow and
click here to get last week's
supernatural video thanking you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you